well a lot of people are really
struggling to find eggs that are at a
decent price everyone from grocery
Shoppers to small business owners are
shelling out big bucks for their
precious commodity Mary Jane beliesa
shares how one restaurant is trying to
crack down on costs
[Music]
as the old saying goes you've got to
break a few eggs to make an omelet and
here at The Omelette Cafe in Sky Canyon
they're trying to do just that without
breaking their bank it's affected us
tremendously I mean we were paying 35 15
dozen eggs last year now we're paying 98
owner Ignacio cesa says they've adjusted
their menu accordingly as egg prices
have increased dramatically he says most
of his customers understand the price
hike as a carton of eggs can cost over
five dollars they were like nine ten
dollars I looked at Albertsons the other
day I still bought them anyway yeah it
was like seven dollars and fifty cents
for the carton so it's pretty crazy
despite eggflation customers like Lynn
Cherry and her family still come to eat
and support local to me it's still worth
the money because eggs is a great
healthy protein and I use them in
everything so I'm not going to stop
cutting down on eggs just because the
price went up I asked cesa if he's
hearing when prices of eggs could crack
our purveyors are anticipating the first
uh or towards the middle of February
until we see some relief we don't know
once we do see some relief we'll we'll
lower our prices I mean accordingly I
mean we're like I said we're here to
make business but we're not here to
gouge our guests we thrive on service
service is huge and it's not about food
it's about service and that's one of the
things that brings our regulars back in